merci aujourd'hui réunis pour parler
d'eux on va parler des opca sorti deux
nouveaux smartphones et le repos est de
retour en france ne suit pas très
longtemps avec notamment le finepix
était présenté au carrousel du louvre
juste officines l'aï reviennent en force
avec le x10 est trop rx 17 néo de
nouveaux smartphones qui ont l'air super
cool plutôt bien positionnée alors
plutôt bien au niveau des technologies
sur ce très intéressant donc ce que je
vous propose ça fait un petit tour
d'aller voir de se manger un petit pain
au chocolat de boire un petit jus
d'orange et de voir si cr x 10 7 pro et
arrive cette néo sont cool
oui non
[Musique]
on est ici on est chez au pot ouais
ouais découvert des nouveaux téléphones
et rx 17,7 propre et fluide mon chez moi
je suis de manger manger elle fixe était
hyper diète pour moi je vais me jeter
sur les poteaux canard et là c'est le
petit jus d'orange aujourd'hui pour un
petit déjeuner pour pouvoir enfin tester
et prendre en main prendre en main sur
tout et c'est ça sera un peu plus tard
c'est le rx 17 proulx est aussi le rx 17
niveaux
donc on est avec des livres qui est
project manager chez ovo merci de dire
merci
alors on a deux nouveaux smartphones rx
17 pro eric 17 mai au 8 août a fait je
l'expliqué rapidement le led l'adn de
chaque produit qu'on comprenne vraiment
ce qu'ils sont et à qui il s'adresse
ok donc je propose cette tendance par le
venue à laisser partir la pièce ok donc
néo voilà c'est ces deux produits la
pièce voir qu'au niveau des couleurs on
a les couleurs qui sont vraiment
sympathiques original et pour une fois
qu'ils sont vraiment distractives à qui
s'adresse le néo je pense c'est vraiment
pour le
la personne qui veut pas casser sa
tirelire on va dire mais toujours avoir
un appareil qui soit déjà beau
esthétiquement qui est des bonnes
performances très ça soit au niveau de
la fluidité de téléphone standard de la
photo c'est un dragon 660 96 60
vous avez un grand écran amoled 6 et 4
pouces résolution 2340 par 1080 pixels à
402 ppp qui vous avez un ratio de 91%
si vous avez la petite encoche qui nous
rappelle franchement celle du wan plus
si c'était ça se fait bien en cette fin
d'année ces petites encoches gouttes
parce que les encoches pour métaux
disparaître mais pour l'instant elles
ont des petites forme de gouttes why not
de campagne et 30 secondes les scènes
même temps je fais chez les copains qui
font défaut top on a deux couleurs alors
temps c'est quoi ça c'est les couleurs
irisées irisé et ça c'est le bleu c'est
un bleu bleu nuit un peu quel accord
avec ça c'est pas trop de conneries
petite nouveauté sur ce modèle on a le
captant un sous l'écran ce qui est à ce
prix là pour l'instant je pense pas
qu'ils aient d'autres
team 17 voire 350 9 940 me 341 349
capteurs sous les crocs cette première
voilà ce prix là je pense qu'il ya pensé
mais sachant que vous avez sans
intriguer mémoire deux ans que didier
drame
donc c'est vraiment quelque chose vous
allez pouvoir regarder 128 go extensible
jusqu'à 256 voilà tout à fait double sim
plus tard psd donc c'est vraiment sous
le choc
ces options on a aussi toujours la prise
jack en dessous ouais ceux qui sont
attachés
voilà gorille la glace 5 sur les deux
faces du téléphone contre les rayures
ces recherches microusb recharge
microusb d'accord parce qu'on n'a pas de
recharge rapide c'est pour ça n'a pas de
recharge rapide sur ce modèle vous allez
sur le micro usb pourquoi pour des
questions de coût ça coûte moins cher
avec un lieu de bêtises alors déjà que
j'avoue que si vous prenez les sirops
des balles au caire ont convenu que non
j'avoue je sais pas en fait je pense que
apple en fait parce qu'en chine si on
n'a pas les forcément les mêmes besoins
sur le marché donc c'est vrai que le
type cc donc c'est très à la mode en
europe c'est moins la mode la main
d'accord ok il serait que type s'est
principalement faite dédié à la charge
rapide
c'est vraiment utile pour l'infographie
c'est donc sur ce modèle là ya pas de
charge rapide d'accords voilà après
attentivement il réussit une praticité
d'utilisation c'est vrai regardez moi
qui arrive la balle alors que pai pas
travailler il ya du monde qui arrive
bonsoir ça suffit maintenant renouveler
cette probabilité à l'égard vous salue
bien ou bien les gars est devenu manger
les toits chocolat le court toujours un
écran toujours le nez l'écran pièces
toujours aussi je veux parler des
capteurs sur la e17 neo à l'avant on a
un capteur 25 méga pixels avec aussi une
technologie hdr mais au niveau hardware
c'est à dire qu'on n'a pas besoin de
traitement il n'ya pas traitement faire
la photo c'est vraiment directement peut
voir la prévisualisation de l'effet et
on voit notamment que si je suis à
contre jour j'arrive quand même à garder
des démons bétail à la croix derrière
elle a pas de vent qui va faire la
différence ici c'est vraiment le capteur
arrière sur le neo en un capteur et 16
12 mégapixels sur le court à avoir un
triple capteurs possède un capteur
principal de 12 mégapixels avec une
ouverture variable f1 points 5 f 2.4 qu
on peut retrouver sur le s9 de samsung
vous avez un deuxième capteur 20 méga
pixels avec l'ouverture de f2 poids 6 kg
capteur 12 mégapixels
ne vous méprenez pas parce que souvent
on a tendance à croire que vous
appréciez le plus c'est bon c'est pas
forcément reste aussi la qualité du
capteur qui fait la différence et sur
place un capteur qui est curieux c'est
par d'autres smartphones très haut de
gamme je vais pas citer les noms pezens
et le capteur secondaire qui va servir
pour tout ce qui est fait bloqué
notamment en profondeur de champ en plus
du hardware donc on a aussi un
stabilisateur optique on a aussi des
optimisations à niveau logicielle en
crise qui est photos demi par exemple et
j'apprends que j'ai pris sur deux photos
tout à l'heure vous passez en mode
normal quand j'active le menu z'allez
voir la différence
ah oui c'est beaucoup plus beaucoup plus
net on a des hautes lumières qui sont
légèrement diminué tout ce qu'ils ont un
peu plus sombre si on veut avoir plus de
détails sur le mode nuit qui abrite dans
le marais sûr ici ça c'est sans ça ça
avec william bourdon logiciels de type
est un vrai travail logiciel qui va
vraiment permettre d'améliorer tout le
monde prendra aussi une autre
optimisation qui est intéressante qui se
trouve ici un sens dans la photo normal
qu'on appelle cartographie de couleur
c'est un peu comme un hdr en fait
lorsque c'est pour les couleurs prendre
des couleurs plus riches
il va vraiment capter directement les
il ya un détecteur des fleurs naturelles
de la scène et après faire des
ajustements au niveau même des pixels
pour ajuster la couleur le contraste etc
et toi tu es ton petit déjeuner pendant
que les gens qui travaillent tous ces
petits déjeuners gay doit bientôt je
viens vous apporter quelques
modifications en seconde c'est 599 euros
sur 198 monochrome et c'est parce que
j'ai dit je sais pas 1900 mais je les
dis enfin ses passagers forcé savage a
déjà droit de me tromper
j'ai le droit de me tromper le mec qui
mettrait presse l'autre gros point fort
de ce téléphone s'arrête la charge
rapide
ual a gouverné sûrs du type c'est pas
deux prises jack par contre mais on
fournit un adaptateur pour lorsque tu
mets est alors silence et 3750 rio
paiera peut être sait il ya deux
batteries de 1855
c'est ça c'est une batterie by cellule
est en fête ok pourquoi on fait ça parce
que ça permet justement d'accélérer la
recharge en fait c'est comme si on avait
un bassin je mets une cloison milieu et
je remplis avec deux filles ou
simplement ça va plus vite qu aux agents
que la recharge rapide de coûts
fonctionnels pas attention insiste
toujours là dessus parce que c'est pas
forcément tous les constructeurs avec le
fond saviez combien il était certes
chauffer la ma fille qui vend clubs
préservés sur la durée on us par mons
pas plus sa batterie en cuisant
or j'ai posé la question tout à l'heure
un peu en ce sens et qu'on n'avait pas
de carte microsd dedans tu me disais que
la brouille est a priori un problème de
place dans le smartphone est oui alors
c'est vrai que là on a une carte
justement la tribu cellulaire va prendre
un peu de glace qui m'intrigue norman
d'accord ici on a aussi le cela inquiète
en dessous du téléphone et qui vend tout
tout petit donc en fait on a juste une
double sim qui sont superposées encore
en dessous comme sur le phénix qu'on
avait présentée il ya quelques temps
glisse sur l'eau effectivement sur la
version neo on va avoir un seul qui va
être sur le côté ici mais qui donc un
peu plus grands permet de mettre deux
cartes sim plus une carte sd voilà vous
avez déjà 128 jigal mémoire en natif se
fait déjà dans la même usine
faut vraiment vouloir pourront voir
beaucoup plus alors si l'on est pour
voter ou s'il veut ça c'est plus au
niveau du système incolore et sans avoir
la barre ce qu'on a appelé la barre
multitâche sur le côté qui va nous
permet depuis en fait n'importe quelle
application par exemple j'ai pas vu sur
facebook je peut switcher directement
avec une hotte applications sans passer
par le menu en te l'enlever pas su aussi
la déplacer peut la mettre là je la
mette à gauche pour les gauchers aussi
choisir du coup les applications que je
mets dedans je peux faire à partir d'ici
une capture d'écran par exemple s'il
veut
sachant que j'ai poussé très facile à
des captures d'écran voilà c'est trois
doigts du haut vers le bas
si je suis sur une application se peut
aussi par exemple ouvrir ma messagerie
sans avoir à quitter mon implication et
un message par exemple
qui fait naître ça c'est valable que ce
soit pour les vidéos les jeux les jeux
aussi je peux ouvrir en tête ma
messagerie sans avoir à quitter le jeu
ou la vidéo alors j'ai une question
tu me dis si je ne répondrai pas
concernant le rx 17 po 599 euros on a un
snapdragon 710 par rapport à les
smartphones comme le one plus citées par
exemple quitte sensiblement dans cette
gamme de prix on savait il a même maison
dans les copeaux forcer une marque fille
est fait d'un coup retiré qui sont
gérées indépendamment mais effectivement
il ya des liens très forts entre est ce
que ça fait partie du même où est ce que
est ce qu'on
est-ce que du coup est ce que ce eric 17
trous pour que ça passe assez facilement
ou est ce que tu pense qu'elles ont fait
la différence par rapport aux
consommateurs en fait je pense mais tous
vaincus s'adresse peut-être à une
population aussi qui est un petit peu
cul surtout qu'ils le prennent pas mal
peut-être un peu plus blick
voilà qui va peut-être chercher plus
vraiment des performances pour m je sais
pas des jeux ou plein de choses et c'est
d'accord peuvent faut savoir que le
sénat 710 pour une utilisation normale
même jour des jeux veut dire moi je me
mets aussi allez je vais sur ces suffit
largement et pas forcément forcément
d'avoir besoin de meilleurs processeurs
pour commencer très fluide et très bien
pu bouger son problème a pu sans
problème en plus on a des optimisations
on collabore justement que ptt béziers
pour avoir d une très bonne fluidité
il faut savoir aussi que sur ce indice
est pour pas qu'on va voir un capteur
qui va être plus qui va être meilleure
que sur le système pour tout ce qui est
photo nuit d'accord voilà ce que vous
avez ouverture le capteur ouverture
notamment ceux ci le capteur qui est pas
le même plus les optimisations qui vont
avec rs niveau là d'accord le point fort
c'est la super enfin la recharge
superbook qui va être beaucoup plus
rapide en 40 minutes vous avez 100% des
batteries chargées ah oui sur le sur le
web que si ses chances d'aller à charge
d'acheminer moins pire c'est comme le
vous avant chez homo ça c'est lui deux
gros avantage de ce téléphone par
rapport aux pour poster gaza dépend
effectivement la population de ce que le
visage que vous voulez en faire ok
voulait faire de très bonnes photos je
vous conseille celui-ci saül niveau du
tarif le modèle pro est à 599 euros
bravo monsieur diesel vous avez
entièrement raison que la nes que le neo
est disponible à 349 euros vous pouvez
le précommander dès aujourd'hui il sera
dispo à partir du 16 novembre donc c'est
très très bientôt moscou la vidéo la
revoilà donc moi j'ai trouvé franchement
bien je pense que t'en pense parler de
celle de trouver ou pas gardiens 2
viennent encadrer
alors trouve qu'ils ont vraiment fait un
bon boulot au niveau du design les bords
arrondis sur le côté c'est vachement
jolie comme un et même niveau du ratio
taille et l'écran et des acadiennes
optimisé pour un téléphone vendu à moins
6 heures 06 92 %
ouais et même pour le néo je pense
qu'aussi c'est pas mal j'attends qu'il
est vendu beaucoup moins cher ça peut
être une bonne alternative pour ceux qui
veulent eux qui hésitent à apprendre aux
nordistes peuvent peut-être regarder
aussi du côté de au pot il propose des
téléphones qui sont plutôt pas mal parce
qu'on se retrouve des chênes toi là bas
on retrouve sur la chaîne rester
connectés et aux directions rendre
hommage
exactement la chaîne match c'est ça un
lundi sur deux oui c'est à 22 22 heures
à 23 heures en direct mais après vous
pouvez le voir sur replay et même en
podcast sur google peut se lire à propos
mine de rien c'est quand même deuxième
constructeur chinois en termes de ventes
en boutiques physiques et c'est pas pour
rien il proposait tfl vraiment
intéressant et chaussées l'un des rares
constructeurs à essayer de d'innover
chalet il essaie d'apporter de nouvelles
choses dites moi ce que vous en pensez
en commentaire dites moi si vous
intéresser au pot est-ce que vous avez
déjà eu des smartphones dopo peut-être
le finepix est ce que vous pourriez vous
laisser tenter par ce r x 10 7 pro neo
qu'est ce que vous pensez du prix
notamment par rapport justement on va de
plus ce système
voilà vous marquez tout ça on reste
connectés on va revoir restez connectés
puis je donne rendez vous très bientôt
soyez sages allez bisous jo